the demand for scale data analysts and
scientists who can derive meaningful in
size from biomedical data has never been
greater and that's where our online meta
guided training program on biomedical
data science using python comes into
play
in today's rapidly evolving world of
biomedical research the generation of
big data has become the norm every day
vast amounts are valuable biomedical
data is being produced holding the
potential to revolutionize our
understanding of diseases and paved the
way for groundbreaking medical
discoveries however the sheer volume and
complexity of this data presents a
significant Challenge and that's where
data analysis comes in
this comprehensive program is designed
to equip you with the knowledge and
skills you need to excel in the field of
biomedical data science
through a combination of practical
assignments live workshops and online
resources you will embark on a
transformative Learning Journey that
will Empower you to unlock the potential
of high throughput biomedical data
python with its versatile and Powerful
libraries has emerged as the guru
language for data analysis and it will
be the Cornerstone of your learning
experience our program will guide you
through the Practical and conceptual
aspects of machine learning in the
context of pre-clinical and clinical
research leveraging python as a
Computing language
our program is divided into three levels
beginner intermediate and advanced
each level builds upon the previous
level providing a comprehensive learning
experience that caters to your specific
needs and expertise
the beginner level training program
serves as a solid foundation in Python
Programming and its applications to
biomedical data science you'll start by
understanding the basics such as data
types variables control structures
functions and modules
then you will dive into data processing
and cleaning using powerful libraries
like numpy and pandas armed with these
skills you will move on to the
expiratory data analysis leveraging
visualization libraries like matplotlib
and c-bond to uncover patterns and
relationships hidden within your data
Additionally you will gain an
understanding of dimensionality
reduction techniques and machine
learning using cited learn
as you progress to the intermediate
level you will deepen your understanding
of clustering and advanced machine
learning techniques specifically
tailored for biomedical data analysis
you'll explore clustering techniques
like k-means hierarchical clustering and
spectral clustering using python
clustering packages like scikit and
scipy you learn about model validation
techniques and evaluation metrics for
supervised machine learning models
furthermore you will delve into the
advanced machine learning techniques
like decision trees random Forest SPM
LDA and umap and apply them to
real-world biomedical data sets finally
in the advanced learning training
program you will tackle complex
biomedical research challenges head on
you will Master feature selection
techniques regression models generalize
linear models network analysis and even
dive into the exciting realm of deep
learning through a captivating case
study and a Capstone project you will
gain practical experience in applying
Advanced Data analysis techniques to
real-world biomedical data sets you'll
learn effective communication of your
findings to diverse audiences a vital
skill for any data scientist
by the end of our Mentor guided training
program you will have developed the
skills and knowledge needed to pursue
further studies and careers in
biomedical data science you will be
equipped to address complex biomedical
research challenges and make a
significant impact in the field
so don't miss out this opportunity to
embark on a transformative Learning
Journey in biomedical data science using
python visit our program page today and
enroll in our mental guided training
program
unlock the door to a world of Limitless
possibilities in biomedical research